what's up y'all weird an insane you're
watching certified country the so vision
lazy I'm so Vishal AC Beauty online
senior music editor by day country music
fan girl also by day but by night and
this is the one show where we can fan
out jam out hangout and I'm gonna be
showing you exclusive interviews with
some of my absolute favorite people in
the whole world
speaking of which did y'all see didn't
say at the top of the show those guys
are first of all an absolute riot and
they recently scored their third
consecutive number-one hit with how not
to
[Music]
in honor of that milestone I want to
share with you guys an interview that I
just did with them behind the scenes at
a recent show in Nashville we are
backstage here in Nashville when these
clowns dan + Shay
yes serious problems we just thought
about it uses microphones yeah a long
week ready first concert you attended
Dave Matthews Band real like a first
album yeah a first album that you
purchased it said ok we're exactly the
first cassette that I this I honestly
couldn't tell you
I think cash and crowns listened to a
lot of Christian rock back then okay mom
yeah she bought that for me so the first
one I have song currently spinning on
repeat uh-huh by Julian Michael's you
know Julian uh-huh I don't see haha we
listen to a lot of samia's that keep got
me onto that and I've been listen to
that non-stop
okay I would definitely mine right now
[Music]
one thing we'd never guess by looking at
you I'm a gamer okay I don't know if you
said that I might look like a game right
I love the game I'm a gamer I went to
college I guess okay yeah what was your
major
a lot of people who go to college don't
wear like spray paint you know I'm gonna
study finance actually Wow yeah
180 here well man is the money that I
don't have okay
I would say like that I didn't go to
college but I think everyone probably
would guess that but you didn't go to
Ohio Widow if you were not an artist
you'd probably be what probably still in
school I like learning yeah you're like
I'll be working construction I've got
under construction company I'll be doing
that thank you guys so much you're so I
always love and hate seeing you both no
I'm just kidding everything right yeah
yeah mostly shake
yeah
[Music]
the guys just announced that
road-tripping is going to be their next
single off the obsessed album perfect
for summer but they also told me that
their next album is very much in the
works very excited about that of course
we also talked about their weddings and
shave adorable baby
Asher's little chunky thing for all
those beats with right here I got to say
that one of my favorite things about my
job here at ET is that I get to check
out new artists before they hit it big
and I want to introduce you all to one
rising star that I'm actually Hueber
super excited about her name is Bailey
Bryan and she's actually label mates
with Dan and Shea over at Warner Music
Nashville take a look right here at her
first music video
it's called own it and this is so like
what's the right lung cancer and fun
fact it is the first music video that
was filmed entirely vertical but I think
Bailey's
awesome and for our first ever interview
together I took to the internet for help
with my questions I actually pulled
these off of a speed dating website
because I think they do a really good
job of like showing us perfect person
behind the star that is Bailey Brian
okay where are you from rich Washington
State what color best describes your
personality
um yellow why because yeah yellow is
like a happy upbeat color and I try and
be happy in a beat what do you consider
one of your best attributes I am happy
and upbeat if you have to be someone
else for a day who would you be and why
Beyonce salad obviously I don't need to
explain that if you won the lottery how
would you spend the money um I would
probably donate a lot of it they won't
various causes so I would donate money
to the Seattle Children's Hospital
because I actually had an operation
there when I was 16 years old and they
helped me out a lot I was diagnosed with
scoliosis when I was 12
okay and then when I was 16 I had
corrective surgery and kind of I don't
know gave me perspective about what it
means to have struggle in life and come
through it and heal and see the world
differently
at something that inspired some songs on
my PC I was going to ask you to I have a
huge scar on my back from my neck - like
mid-back but I mean if scar represents
more than just something physical
something has impacted us us and I think
that can be a positive thing
[Music]
what is the most adventurous thing
you've ever done I ate gas station sushi
one time that's just silly
some would call it an adventure vehicle
but are you okay I'm fine I lived I
wouldn't I don't want to go into details
about it again no okay tell me your best
joke oh okay all right
where do you stay when you have a lot of
dough pencils what is real point that's
not how it goes at all good joke
it would be if I said it correctly I
like corny jokes okay for real how cute
is Bailey her EP so far is out now and
she's also working on a full-length
album but she hasn't announced a release
date just yet
and that's a wrap on our very first
episode of certified country come back
and see us again
every Friday right here on a TV YouTube
channel but before next week
I am giving you all a little homework
and that is to check out my song picks
of the week now these are songs that
I've got playing on a three-peat and I
want you all to let me know what you
think by commenting on Instagram I am at
Sophie Chalet see and here they are
Julianne Jacqueline bleachers
[Music]
raelynne lonely call
[Music]
and Maren Morris's boo Ryan heard with
love in a bar
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
happy listening I'll see you next week
but in the meantime be sure to click
subscribe on e t--'s youtube channel and
check out my boo jenny directive on the
daily Benny for your weekly dose of
celeb scoop bye for now
[Music]